Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Io parto con una domanda:
il cibo può comunicare con il nostro DNA?
E se comunica con il nostro DNA,
può influenzare la salute?
Pensiamo a una prima immagine: alle api.
Abbiamo tre tipi di api:
l'ape operaia, il fuco, e l'ape regina.
Tutte e tre hanno il medesimo DNA,
il medesimo genoma;
ma l'ape regina
è stata nutrita dalla larva
con un cibo diverso: la pappa reale.
E come vediamo, le dimensioni
dell'ape regina sono differenti.
Ma non solo le dimensioni:
la sua funzione è differente.
È l'unica, all'interno dell'arnia,
che si può riprodurre,
che può dare origine a una nuova colonia.
Allora il cibo ha comunicato
qualcosa al DNA,
perché tutte hanno lo stesso DNA.
E per capire questo,
dobbiamo addentrarci nel molto piccolo,
nel nucleo delle nostre cellule.
Due micron, che racchiudono
tre miliardi di basi,
che è il nostro genoma, lungo circa
due metri, molto impacchettato.
Pensate che alla fine degli anni Novanta
si pensava che dallo studio
del genoma umano
si avrebbero avuto grandi risposte
sia di comprensione delle malattie
ma anche di comprensione sul DNA.
In realtà si è capito
che eravamo solo all'inizio,
perché solo il due - tre percento del DNA
codifica per una proteina,
e pertanto una funzione.
Tutto il resto - pensate, il 98% -
è un DNA che all'epoca
era considerato "junk DNA",
scusate il termine inglese.
"Spazzatura" che serviva come backup
per far sì che le mutazioni
cadessero non sui geni.
In realtà, con questo DNA si è scoperto
che eravamo all'inizio
di una nuova avventura:
questo DNA era funzionale
a regolare l'espressione dei geni.
E come?
Ci sono dei marcatori chimici sul DNA,
delle bandierine che, durante lo sviluppo,
vengono apposte sul DNA.
Queste bandierine,
che possono essere o dirette sul DNA
o sulle proteine che avvolgono il DNA,
o addirittura su alcuni RNA,
che sono lo stampo del DNA anti-senso,
vengono poste durante lo sviluppo
affinché le cellule
possano compiere la loro funzione.
Pensate che noi abbiamo,
nelle nostre cellule,
in ogni nostra cellula,
lo stesso medesimo DNA.
Ma ogni cellula svolge
una funzione differente: perché?
Perché ha le prime parti
del DNA differente,
grazie a queste bandierine,
questi marcatori che dicono a un gene:
tu devi essere espresso in questa cellula,
devi far sì che questa cellula
abbia questa funzione
e un'altra cellula un'altra.
Per capire meglio,
immaginiamo che il nostro DNA
sia uno spartito orchestrale,
e che i geni siano gli strumenti.
Se suonassero tutti insieme,
non ci sarebbe un'armonia,
non ci sarebbe una sinfonia.
Non sarebbe la musica,
sarebbe solo rumore.
In realtà, ogni gene sa perfettamente,
grazie a queste bandierine, questi marker,
quando entrare in funzione,
quando suonare, quando stare zitto,
se suonare forte, se suonare piano.
Ecco, questa armonia si svolge
in ogni secondo, in ogni istante,
all'interno delle nostre cellule.
E c'è uno studio estremamente interessante
fatto sui topi -
nella biologia si parte sempre
da un modello sperimentale,
e spesso sono i topi.
A due mamme con la stessa genetica
è stato dato da mangiare del cibo.
A una mamma del cibo povero,
povero di nutrienti;
a un'altra mamma hanno dato da mangiare
un cibo ricco di nutrimento.
E soprattutto, particolari
nutrienti, vitamine.
Il risultato è stato
che i cuccioli di queste due mamme
hanno avuto un fenotipo,
cioè una manifestazione
di quello in cui sono differenti -
addirittura il colore
del manto è cambiato,
perché il cibo ha comunicato
una cosa differente,
durante lo sviluppo
di questi cuccioli, ai geni.
Allora pensiamo al cibo ai nostri giorni.
Abbiamo su questo piccolo pianeta,
come dice Edgar Morin,
persone che muoiono di fame,
persone che mangiano in eccesso,
abbiamo spreco di cibo.
Abbiamo persone che si ammalano
perché mangiano troppo, mangiano male.
E abbiamo anche
una situazione paradossale,
chiamata deserto nutrizionale:
io esco di casa, e in dieci minuti
non riesco a recuperare
cibo ricco di vitamine.
Riesco a recuperare
solo il cibo cosiddetto -
non mi piace il termine, perché del cibo
bisogna sempre avere rispetto -
cibo che ha solo calorie
ma non ha nutrienti essenziali.
E la cosa più interessante
è che l'ambiente, il cibo,
lo stile di vita e anche le emozioni
possono scrivere sul DNA.
Possono parlare, col DNA.
E questo scrivere può essere trasmesso -
soprattutto se questo avviene
durante i primi 1.000 giorni
di vita del bambino,
dal concepimento al terzo anno di età -
questa scrittura può passare
anche da una generazione a un'altra.
C'è un'evidenza storica
di questo passaggio intergenerazionale
di quanto l'ambiente, e il cibo,
abbiano influenzato la salute
delle generazioni successive.
Questo è uno studio storico,
avvenuto in Olanda.
Si è studiata una popolazione
di 45 milioni di persone olandesi,
che durante la Seconda Guerra Mondiale
fu confinata in una zona
molto ristretta dell'Olanda.
Era inverno: da una parte
c'erano le truppe tedesche,
dall'altra parte i canali ghiacciati.
Questa popolazione visse,
per nove mesi circa,
mangiando pochissimo, di stenti:
arrivarono addirittura a mangiare,
pensate, i bulbi dei tulipani.
E si calcolò che mangiarono
circa 500 Kcal al giorno.
Si sono studiati i bambini nati
dalle mamme che durante quel periodo
erano in gravidanza, e che aspettavano.
Questi bambini hanno mantenuto
la "programmazione" delle loro mamme:
le loro mamme avevano vissuto senza cibo,
e quando sono nati, questi bimbi
erano programmati a resistere
all'assenza di cibo.
A guerra poi finita,
hanno avuto accesso al cibo
e questi bimbi sono stati più esposti
a una vulnerabilità sanitaria:
più esposti a diabete, obesità,
sovrappeso, malattie cardiovascolari
e anche tumori.
E questa vulnerabilità,
questo aumento di rischio
si è anche ripresentato nella seconda
e adesso si sta studiando
la terza generazione.
Alllora dobbiamo pensare dal piccolo,
perché il piccolo ci possa suggerire
delle azioni da fare nel grande,
per migliorare la società
e per migliorare, anche,
l'aspettativa di salute
della nostra società,
e ripensare all'origine delle malattie.
Ed è il modo migliore
di promuovere la salute:
portare la scienza del piccolo,
questi meccanismi meravigliosi
che avvengono nelle nostre cellule,
nelle scelte grandi.
Investire soprattutto sulle classi
che hanno meno consapevolezza
di tutto questo.
Che hanno accesso a cibo povero,
perché costa poco,
perché hanno magari un basso reddito,
perché magari hanno anche
una bassa scolarizzazione
che non li può far accedere
a questi tipi di messaggi.
E soprattutto, investire nelle mamme,
perché il diritto alla salute,
sancito anche dalla Costituzione,
sia un diritto, anche,
di giustizia intergenerazionale.
Dobbiamo pensare alla nostra salute,
[che è] un bene prezioso,
ma pensare anche di poterla trasmettere
alle generazioni successive.
E allora dobbiamo un po' risvegliarci,
e questo è il mio risveglio.
C'è un'origine che pone
una vulnerabilità maggiore alle malattie:
sono importanti i primi 1.000 giorni
di vita del bambino.
E c'è forse, questa è una domanda
che mi faccio sempre,
un'evoluzione silenziosa,
che porta una società
ad avere una prospettiva di salute
diversa rispetto a un'altra,
perché c'è un accesso al cibo differente?
E questa evoluzione continuerà?
Per fortuna può essere reversibile,
se le condizioni cambiano.
E se il cibo, che ovviamente
mangia la mamma, mangiamo noi, cambia.
Allora, se è vero che è importante,
per la salute dei nascituri
e anche delle generazioni successive,
l'ambiente, il cibo che mangia la mamma,
allora dobbiamo curare il cibo
e tutto ciò che è l'ambiente
attorno alle mamme,
attorno a quelle che sono le nuove vite.
Allora dobbiamo pensare ogni momento
in cui una persona mangia.
E curare, questo momento.
Può essere l'ospedale:
non possiamo lasciare che il cibo
diventi solo un servizio alberghiero.
Il cibo deve trasmettere dei valori:
deve essere importante
trasmettere anche salute.
Alle scuole, dove tanti genitori
sono più preoccupati
se i bambini non mangiano,
ma mai si preoccupano
se il bambino mangia male.
Sempre la preoccupazione:
mio figlio non mangia.
Ma preoccupiamoci di cosa mangia,
preoccupiamoci se quello che mangia
è importante per la sua salute.
Poi ci sono le aziende:
in ogni momento, ma anche tra amici,
un marketing della salute
che può essere, anche,
trasversale nella società.
Pensiamo, in ogni momento
in cui si mangia,
quanto possiamo comunicare
attraverso un cibo.
Deve essere sempre buono,
ma anche funzionale alla salute.
Perché il cibo è un interconnessione
tra il nostro passato, al nostro presente
ma anche al nostro futuro.
Ci interconnette con la Terra,
perché il cibo è lavoro:
viene prodotto e viene trasformato,
dobbiamo averne grande rispetto.
Con gli esseri viventi, con l'ambiente.
Diceva una grande agronoma inglese
che la salute dell'uomo, degli animali,
della terra, dell'acqua e dell'aria
è unica e indivisibile.
E poi pensiamo: noi ci nutriamo
di molecole che sono i carboidrati,
dove il carbonio è in uno stato chimico
di legame ad alta energia.
E questo legame ad alta energia
lo ricava da che cosa?
Dalle piante!
Perché le piante invece trasformano,
grazie all'energia solare,
una molecola di carbonio,
che ha un legame a bassa energia, CO2,
in ossigeno ad alta energia.
Per la proprietà transitiva,
noi possiamo dire che mangiamo
grazie all'energia del Sole.
Quindi dobbiamo rispettare
questo tipo di ambiente intorno a noi.
Ci ricollega all'interconnessione
con noi stessi, con la nostra storia.
Pensiamo ai profumi
che ci evocano delle emozioni,
i profumi della cucina della nonna.
Pensiamo a Proust e alle Madeleine.
Pensiamo a quanto il cibo
lega la tradizione, la storia:
è parte del nostro passato
ma è parte anche nel nostro futuro.
Ed è parte, anche,
di quello che possiamo trasmettere
alle generazioni successive.
A volte, invece, si mangiano
anche cibi standard,
con dei profumi standard
e sapori standard,
e questo penso sia uno svilimento
di quello che è
un nostro organo di senso.
Perché abbiamo cinque organi di senso,
e l'organo di senso del gusto
è un organo meraviglioso:
abbiamo attraverso il gusto cinque gusti,
ma attraverso l'organo
vomero-nasale, e l'olfatto,
milioni di possibilità
di apprezzare sapori e profumi.
A volte il cibo è industriale,
molto processato,
e un cibo che è sempre lo stesso,
sempre uguale.
E dobbiamo investire
nella cultura del cibo,
che è una cultura diversa
dalla prevenzione,
però possono avere davvero
dei link in comune.
E poi nutrire è il primo atto
che svolge la mamma, nutrire e amare.
Un cibo che nutre è un cibo che ama.
E poi, ovviamente, le nostre tradizioni.
Le nostre tradizioni che fanno sì
che ci sia un quotidiano
più frugale, ma sempre buono,
e una festa che dobbiamo
aspettare e attendere
per poter condividere
un cibo più ricco con i nostri cari.
E allora l'epigenetica che cos'è?
De "epi", greco, "sopra" il DNA.
Tutte queste modifiche sopra il DNA.
È un ponte che lega l'ambiente -
ahimè, anche l'inquinamento -
le emozioni, il cibo,
che è un po tutto questo, al nostro DNA.
Pensavamo che il DNA
fosse un codice immutabile:
alto; basso; occhi azzurri; occhi neri.
In realtà abbiamo capito,
attraverso questi ultimi studi -
che non sono poi così recenti,
perché ormai sono 15 anni
che si studia in questo senso -
che possiamo avere un dialogo col DNA,
e possiamo anche trasmettere
la nostra storia
alle generazioni successive.
Per, io penso, una prospettiva di salute
più equa e uguale per tutti.
E per permettere alle nuove generazioni
di avere anche meno vulnerabilità
a determinate malattie.
Grazie.
(Applausi)